okay leute ich weiß ja nicht wie tief
wir in der akku babbel drin steckt aber
es gibt ein material das die fachwelt
gerade mehr als alles andere
interessiert wenn man insidern vertrauen
kann dann könnten wir bald den
vielleicht größten flaschenhals von
e-autos überwinden nämlich die kapazität
des akkus frühe prototypen versprechen
jetzt schon 1000 kilometer reichweite
und die tendenz steigt
aber ist das wieder nur eine weitere
wunder batterie von der wir nach heute
nie wieder irgendwas hören oder ist das
wirklich mal ein echter durchbruch den
wir auch auf der straße sind wir haben
genau darum geht es jetzt bei doktor
watson
okay noch mal ganz kurz die basics der
aufbau einer batteriezelle ist im grunde
genommen immer gleich eine negative
elektrode auf der einen seite eine
positive elektrode auf der anderen
dazwischen ein elektrolyt und ein
separator beim laden und entladen werden
lithium ionen von einer elektrode zur
anderen geschickt und andersherum ihr
dürft euch die anode nicht als einen
starren block aus einem material
vorstellen stattdessen besteht sie aus
ganz vielen kleinen partikeln die durch
eine art kleber dem bindemittel
zusammengehalten werden und auf einem
strom ableiter liegen der den strom von
den elektroden einsammelt und zurzeit
ist graphit das gängigste an
notenmaterial in allen lithium ionen
batterien etwa 99 prozent der lithium
ionen batterien nutzen graphit das ganze
hat aber einen haken und zwar die
kapazität graphit kann relativ wenig
lithium ionen programm speichern was
unter anderem dazu führt dass man sich
beim weihnachtsessen anhören darf dass
diese autos ja ganz nett sind aber man
damit niemals bis nach italien in den
urlaub fahren kann grund genug sich also
mal um ein update gedanken zu machen und
dafür brauchen wir das
elektrodenmaterial der zukunft vorhang
auf für silizium silizium besitzt eine
immens hohe theoretische kapazität von
etwa dem zehnfachen von graphit wichtig
theoretisch aber was das genau bedeutet
dazu kommen wir gleich noch
das silizium so vielversprechend ist
liegt daran dass ein silizium atome vier
lithium ionen speichern kann zum
vergleich bei graphit was ja nichts
anderes ist als kohlenstoff sind sechs
kohlenstoffatome nötig um ein lithium
nun zu speichern anders gesagt für die
anzahl an lithium-ionen die ein silizium
atome speichern kann bräuchte man 24
kohlenstoff atome aber das ist nicht
alles silizium gibt es im wahrsten sinne
des wortes wie sand am meer denn es ist
das am zweithäufigsten vorkommende
element in der erdkruste es ist außerdem
umweltfreundlich und günstig also das
perfekte material für die batterie der
zukunft nun ja nicht ganz denn es gibt
zwei haken an der ganzen sache erstens
während der speicherung von lithium
ionen erhöht sich das volumen von
fusionen um etwa 300 bis 400 prozent
dabei entstehen risse im material und es
bricht sprichwörtlich beim laden
auseinander dadurch verliert schnell an
stabilität und elektrischen kontakt mit
den benachbarten partikeln dh die
batterie alt hat ziemlich schnell und
die lebenszeit ist kurz denn naja
elektrischer kontakt ist ziemlich
wichtig für ein material das
elektrizität speichern soll
zweitens eigentlich bildet sich beim
ersten auf ladezyklus einer batterie
eine stabile schutzschicht auf dem
graphit die wichtig für die performance
ist dabei werden einmalig lithium ionen
gefressen auf denen sich ausdehnenden
silizium partikeln ist diese
schutzschicht allerdings nicht stabil
und baut sich immer wieder auf und ab
und frisst dabei weitere lithium ionen
wodurch die kapazität der zelle weiter
und weiter abnimmt und das leider sehr
schnell okay aber wie löst man diese
zwei probleme bevor wir dazu kommen will
ich eine minute über andere probleme
sprechen denn wie wir alle wissen ist
eines der größten probleme vielleicht
das größte problem unserer zeit die
klimakrise und genau deswegen
unterstützen wir die app klima mit klima
kannst du klimaneutral leben indem du
direkt aus der app heraus seine co2
emissionen offset ist also ausgleichstor
dafür berechnet die app mit hilfe
einiger fragen zu deinem leben einem
persönlichen monatlichen beitrag mit dem
du eins oder mehrere ausgewählte umwelt
projekte finanzieren kannst die projekte
binden oder reduzieren dann für dich co2
etwa durch den ausbau von solarenergie
in entwicklungsländern ganz transparent
von deinen beiträgen fließen 70 prozent
direkt in die projekte zehn prozent in
die entwicklung und den betrieb der app
und die verbleibenden 20 prozent
finanzieren das marketing also zum
beispiel auch dieses video hier gerade
das von klima gesponsert wurde wenn wir
unseren code benutzt dann unterstützen
damit unsere videos und auch dass wir
über mehr nachhaltigkeitsthemen sprechen
und außerdem könnt ihr damit zehn extra
bäume spenden dafür müsst ihr nur
unseren code dr watson in der app
eingeben im durchschnitt kostet es
weniger als 10 euro monat die kompletten
co2-emission deines lebens zu oft hätten
und on top gibt es in der app auch noch
viele gute tipps um klimafreundlicher zu
leben und gar nicht erst co2 emission zu
verursachen das klingt alles etwas
komisch hier haben wir uns an ein video
kritisch mit der app auseinandergesetzt
und all diese aussagen auch hinterfragt
schaut euch das gerne mal an ansonsten
kommen wir jetzt wieder zurück zum thema
ok also was tun wir gegen die zwei
großen haken von silizium naja
eigentlich haben wir schon ein material
was ganz gut als schutzschicht
funktioniert grafit das ergebnis eine
silizium kohlenstoff komposit anode die
silizium partikel werden dabei in einer
art hohe kugel aus kohlenstoff
eingeschlossen um die volumen expansion
des siliziums zu puffern und dennoch
nicht den elektrischen kontakt zu
verlieren und es gibt noch einen
weiteren vorteil der kohlenstoff schirmt
das hungrige silizium vor neben
reaktionen mit dem elektrolyt auch
grafen dass wir schon in diesem video
hier besprochen haben kann dafür
eingesetzt werden das hat ja noch
vielversprechendere eigenschaften als
graphit denn es leitet elektrischen
strom ausgezeichnet und kann ionen
übertragen alles klar silizium ist tot
lang lebe silizium kohlenstoff komposit
das silizium so fit für unsere akkus
gemacht wird kommt aber mit einem preis
die theoretische kapazität von reinem
silizium erreichen wir so natürlich
nicht trotzdem verdreifachen wir mit
silizium kohlenstoff komposit die
kapazität der anode im vergleich zu
reinen im graphit und das haben auch
autohersteller spitz bekommen deswegen
ist diese batterie chemie auch das thema
aktuell tesla verbaut bereits seit 2005
zehn zellen von panasonic mit einem
silizium gehalt von 5 prozent in der
anode ab 2025 wollen bereits mehrere
autohersteller silizium in höheren
anteilen in ihren akku verbauen dabei
wird es aber nicht bleiben
um das volle potenzial auszuschöpfen
will man zukünftig reine silizium anoden
in die batteriezellen einbauen porsche
plant bereits eine silizium
fertigungsanlage und mercedes und bmw
investieren in silano einem silizium
anoden startup nach eigener angabe
forschen die köpfe hinter dem start up
bereits seit über acht jahren an
silizium anoden und behaupten die
probleme des siliziums nach über 50.000
versuchen im labor endlich gelöst zu
haben und die investition scheint sich
auszuzahlen denn immerhin hat mercedes
vor kurzem ein prototyp fahrzeug mit
einer reichweite von 1000 kilometern
vorgestellt ermöglicht durch die antes
silizium anoden technik und auch das
unternehmen empires technologies hat
silizium anoden akkus entwickelt und
verkauft diese sogar schon seit wenigen
wochen an einen satelliten hersteller es
ist also wirklich keine wunder batterie
von der wir nie wieder etwas hören
sondern tatsächlich ein echter
durchbruch in der batterietechnologie
den wir wirklich auf den straßen sehen
werden das e-auto mit 1000 kilometern
reichweite wird man kaufen und fahren
können da kommt nur eine frage auf wie
eben schon erwähnt dehnt sich silizium
soweit aus bis es kleine risse gibt die
dafür sorgen dass das material nicht
lange hält wie wurde das problem gelöst
kann man dass ihr auto nur drei mal
aufladen und danach ist der akku kaputt
vermutlich nicht aber die kurze antwort
ist wir haben keine ahnung denn
natürlich halten die firmen die details
ihrer forschung noch geheim und das ist
auch der grund warum man aus
wissenschaftlicher sicht erst mal noch
ein bisschen vorsichtig sein sollte denn
am ende ist fast alles was wir haben
beeindruckende benchmarks im labor und
versprechen ohne frei zugängliche daten
dennoch gibt es ein paar
vielversprechende hinweise sagen wir mal
wenn man weiß wo man suchen muss eine
lösung könnte sein silizium nano
partikel zu verwenden das heißt dass die
silizium partikel aus dem die anode
bestehen soll unter einem durchmesser
von 100 50 nanometern bleiben in dieser
größenordnung wird sich die volumen
ausdehnung der partikel beim speichern
von lithium ionen nämlich nicht so
zerstörend auf sie aus da bleibt nur ein
problem beim laden und entladen wird die
schützende schicht auf den partikeln ja
immer wieder zerstört auch beim nano
ansatz die lösung von sila nano ist nach
wie vor wie bei dem graphit silizium
komposit ansatz die silizium partikel
mit einem material zu umhüllen und sie
damit vor diesen reaktionen zu schützen
nur dieses mal ohne graphit weil dieses
jahr die kapazität drastisch verringert
dabei darf die hülle allerdings nicht zu
eng am silizium kernanliegen um dem
silizium genug platz zum ausdehnen zu
lassen die firma embryos hingegen setzt
auf silizium nanodrähte in der mitte des
drahtes befindet sich der leiter der
silizium festhält und so den
elektrischen kontakt gewährleistet die
drähte sind ausreichend voneinander
entfernt sodass das silizium genug platz
für seine volumen ausdehnung hat das
hört sich ja alles eigentlich schon mal
ziemlich gut an hier dürfen wir aber
nicht vergessen dass firmen auf ihrer
eigenen website natürlich ein etwas
optimistischeres bild zeichnen aber auch
in der fachliteratur finden sich sehr
ähnliche ansätze das heißt so
unrealistisch ist das alles nicht es
bleibt nur die große frage ob die labor
erfolge auch hochskaliert werden können
und in der anwendung genau so gute
ergebnisse liefern
[Musik]
auch mit reinem silizium oder mit einem
erhöhten anteil silizium an noten
batterien kommen und werden unseren
mobilen geräten und e autos vor allem
einen ordentlichen kapazitäts boost
geben daran besteht inzwischen kein
zweifel mehr klar es gibt noch
hindernisse aber die ansätze das alles
in den griff zu bekommen sehen bisher
gut aus allerdings eine sache muss man
bei aller euphorie um dieses an
notenmaterial dennoch berücksichtigen
eine batterie besteht natürlich nicht
nur aus anode sondern auch aus vielen
anderen materialien die gar nicht aktiv
energie speichern dazu gehört zum
beispiel die verpackung selbst wenn man
also reines silizium einsetzt das ja
eine zehnmal höhere spezifische
kapazität besitzt als graphit wird man
mit einem silizium auto nicht zehnmal
weiterfahren können realistisch ist er
eine erhöhung der batteriekapazität von
10 nach der einführung und auf bis zu 40
prozent in der nächsten generation von
elektroautos bis silizium das heute in
den batterien eingesetzte graphit
komplett ersetzen wird werden wohl aber
noch ein paar jahre vergehen bis dahin
bleiben aber natürlich noch
kompositmaterialien aus graphit und
silizium das passiert jetzt gerade und
es quasi ein kleiner vorgeschmack auf
das was in zukunft alles mit hilfe von
silizium möglich sein wird und damit
haben sich dann vielleicht auch endlich
mal die nervigen diskussionen an
weihnachten erledigt bei denen man e
autos verteidigen muss falls euch das
schon mal passiert ist dann schaut euch
am besten mal dieses video hier an die
wahrheit über e autos da wollen wir mal
mit wirklich allen mythen zu diesem
thema auf vier legs zuschauern und bis
zur nächsten woche bleibt neugierig
patrick